[Musique]
bonsoir comme tennis
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
françois nouvelle étape 1 dans le
déconfinement aujourd'hui en belgique
quelles sont vos attentes particulières
à anvers retour il expekt oui mais ça
c'est bien
nous suivons les consignes du
gouvernement fédéral mais nous espérons
que dans les semaines ou les mois à
venir et cela également vrai pour
l'hôtellerie les restaurants il y aura
un assouplissement et qu'ils pourront à
réouvrir à l'avenir nous le savons que
c'est un processus très lent nous sommes
déjà très heureux que les commerces
réouvre et que même si cela va lentement
comme vous avez pu le voir sur les
images
c'est comme à bruxelles les gens
viennent et nous sommes très heureux
qu'il vienne mais en tout cas c'est
certain il faut respecter les mesures
d'hygiène nécessaires afin d'assurer la
sécurité de tout le monde alors on l'a
dit vous êtes particulièrement en charge
du tourisme et de la mobilité vous
montrer raisonnable vous êtes ravi déjà
que les commerces ouvrent vous attendait
évidemment avec impatience qu'il y ait
plus de flexibilité sur les restaurants
est ce que vous proposez vous en amont
des aménagements de façon à pouvoir
peut-être les rouvrir plus vite au verso
date homicide en suède je suis très
heureux parce que nous voyons les
entrepreneurs les personnes gèrent la
situation maintenant je les restaurants
les cafés les hôtels les entrepreneurs
du tourisme le sont extrêmement
sportif ils réfléchissent beaucoup la
façon dont ils peuvent changer la façon
de faire des affaires de travailler afin
de pouvoir accueillir les clients
rapidement dans les restaurants qui
calment et nous en service très heureuse
que le zoo d'anvers offrira lundi serein
des essais avec les personnes qui nous
tendent l'abonnement mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il est de ce travail
et il étudie des aménagements afin de
recouvrir à partir de lundi et cela nous
apprendra pas et j'espère bien sûr que
cela sera la même chose pour les cafés
le seuil s'applique également par
l'initiateur à trouver des façons de
mettre en place et consignes trouver de
meilleures pratiques afin de pouvoir
commencer le travail
on rappelle aussi qu'en vert est l'un
des plus grands ports au monde donc
énormément des changes de commerce
on imagine que cette séquence a été
terrible d'un point de vue économique
quelles sont vos attentes de ce point de
vue là ouverture du tour à 100% est une
très bonne nouvelle
content parce que c'était vraiment très
important pour le reste de l'europe
beaucoup de produits par exemple ces
produits alimentaires et les plans
sanitaire passe par anvers de ce point
de vue donc l'économie à anvers
fonctionne encore mais continue et nous
espérons qu'au cours des mois à venir
l'économie le commerce même s'il est
plus loin continuera tout et cela ça va
peut-être due à l'accumulation de
produits dans le port et aux problèmes
de production dans le reste du monde les
la liaison on imagine qu'il a énormément
voilà de liaison avec la chine on dans
ce port qui est très important vous
l'avez souligné
pour l'europe rapidement les liaisons
reprennent quasi normalement avec la
chine comment ça va se passer ces
prochains temps donné ce moment précis
dans les échanges de près nos jeunes
russes les échanges avec la chine et
l'asie reprennent mais il faudra voir ce
qui va se passer
l'avantagent d'anvers et que le commerce
vient du monde entier
et s'il ya des problèmes dans une région
alors ce n'est pas un problème majeur
peut s'adapter
merci beaucoup kun kenny ces chemins
pour le tourisme et la mobilité de la
ville d'anvers d'avoir été avec mots
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir